hey guys it is the sixth of May today
and I'm ninety percent sure nothing cool
is happening but I was wrong yesterday
so who knows I'm Jessie mrs. James bun
use sony must be holding all the cards
close this year the company have opted
out of their regular gamescom conference
for 2015 sony told GameSpot that instead
of their regularly scheduled gamescom
conference they plan to hold an
international media briefing at paris
games week on the 27th top of its Hoover
the publisher explained to quote with
the changes this year of e3 taking place
a week later and gamescom taking place
earlier we feel the both PlayStation and
the wider industry would benefit from a
major news milestone later in the year
during the most important period for
gaming whether that means what they say
it means or they just have nothing all
that much to announce at Gamescom is up
to you to decide microsoft and nintendo
are also expected to be at paris games
week PT is officially dead but not just
on the playstation store front the
playable teaser for the council of
silent Hills has now been taken off the
PlayStation servers that means even if
you added the game to your ps4 library
before it was gone from the store you're
no longer able to download it basically
once it's gone it's gone so don't delete
it if you're lucky enough to have it
installed on your console if you're
lapping up all the witcher 3 goodness
that you can then 1080p ps4 gameplay
footage probably qualifies as your thing
of course you've probably already seen
the pc footage which looks better anyway
but if you're keen to get into this one
on the ps4 and want to know how it's
going to look here's your chance
PlayStation access have posted a five
minute video that covers various
environments combat and plenty of horse
riding the ps4 edition runs at 1080p and
30 frames per second and the game will
be out on May nineteen let me know down
in the comments what you think of the
witcher 3 ps4 gameplay footage and what
platform you want
tell you the game on you can have two
games for we've got stories on the
oculus rift release date and a potential
destiny content pack that's everything I
wanted to tell you about today do enjoy
the rest of your day and i'll catch you
again tomorrow